they ran a spy ring or an informant ring
and they were paying people within the
Trump campaign if any of that is true
that is an absolute redline that's
claimed by the president's suggestion by
Giuliani that there is a political spy
embedded in the Trump campaign is
nonsense for the president I think is
grateful that the Department of Justice
is going to have the Inspector General
look into it and determine and ensure
that there was no surveillance done for
political purposes against our campaign
well this is the talk what is the the
deal with this investigation the
president saying these reports of a spy
and informant inside his campaign he
wants to get to the bottom of it today
meeting with the FBI director the Deputy
Attorney General and the Director of
National Intelligence dan coates we
don't know exactly what was in that
meeting but we're told that he was
talking about this the DOJ put out a
statements and the Department has asked
the inspector general to expand the
ongoing review of the FISA application
process to include determining whether
there was any impropriety or political
motivation and how the FBI conducted its
counterintelligence investigation of
persons suspected of involvement with
the Russian agents who interfered in the
2016 presidential election as always the
Inspector General will conduct the
appropriate u.s. will consult the
appropriate US attorney if there's any
evidence of potential criminal conduct
Rosenstein with his own statement saying
if anyone did infiltrate were surveil
participants in the presidential
campaign for inappropriate purposes we
need to know about it and take
appropriate action so with that let's
bring in our panel from Washington
general goldberg senior editor at
national review a be Stoddard associate
editor at RealClearPolitics
and Katie Pavlich news editor at
townhall.com
Jonah this this seemed to pick up steam
and obviously it was fueled by the
president's tweets about all of this
ongoing the fact that the Inspector
General is now taking this what do you
think that tells us I think it tells us
that there is credible reason to look
take a harder look at what
going on in 2016 in terms of the
investigation of the Trump campaign at
the same time I think the talk about
this guy as far as what we know now
being a spy embedded with the campaign
is hyperbole having three conversations
with people about their contacts with
Russia that we know about is not an
embedded spy it is maybe it's an
informant but it's not quite what people
are making it out to be I think the key
word or the key phrase in Rosenstein
statement was you know for any
inappropriate purpose I think that there
is ample reason that they maybe should
have looked into Russian collusion or
reports our suspicions of it but if
there was other reasons why they were
doing or if they were trying to undo our
hurt president Trump or if there was a
reason to believe there was political
motivation that would be very bad and
it's worth looking into yeah Katie your
thoughts and all this as it's developing
well it's a good thing that the Justice
Department is willing to look at this
further but they'd be bumping it over to
the Inspector General is prudent given
that the people involved in potential
misuse for abuse of power during the
2016 election are still working inside
the Justice Department or at the FBI the
Inspector General doesn't have
jurisdiction to interview political
appointees who have worked in the Obama
administration who may now be gone and I
would get back to all the noise
surrounding this issue comes down to I
mean what launched a special counsel in
the first place whether they were legal
instances of authority being abused in
the 2016 campaign for political purposes
and the question is you look at when
this investigation happened after the
Hillary Clinton campaign investigation
wrapped up then the Trump campaign was
allegedly getting you know an informant
was giving information to the FBI well
if it was really just about Russian
surveillance and you know interference
in the election then why didn't the
investigation start earlier in 2015 when
the Obama administration knew that
Russia I plan to meddle in our elections
yeah here's Devon Nunez a be talking
about trying to get the doc
documentation
and all we're asking for is give us the
documentation that you used to start
this investigation we're trying to get
to the bottom of you know what else was
used in that FISA because you have many
people within the Department of Justice
who are claiming that we're wrong so if
we're wrong
show us the information we're told a
judge has received that but Capitol Hill
has not well Bret this is a big battle
about the separation of powers and what
congressional investigators can do in
their oversight roles to force documents
from the Department of Justice and which
documents after rod Rosen Stein has
given many many many documents he's
resisting providing these with
Republican members of the House on the
Intel committee and they basically this
is a struggle to define what is you know
within the purview of oversight and what
is overreach I've spoken to people who
you know or have their concerns about
how the FBI might have conducted the
Hillary Clinton investigation but still
say you can't share raw intelligence
from an investigation that could be
provided to the witnesses so today you
had DNI who had FBI everyone huddling
with President Trump and Rudy Giuliani
who's on a PR campaign demanding that he
can't sit for an interview with the
special counsel unless we know about
other witnesses that were revealed in a
New York Times story this week this
weekend who have met with John Jr you
can't demand that you that you can't be
given information on a witness in
exchange for talking to the special
counsel he says the meeting today in
which the demands for these documents is
being made and reiterated by the
president he was doing that in his
capacity not as a subject of the Muller
investigation but as president estates
to make sure that Congress is getting
what they need from the executive branch
so they're doing a really really good
job of muddying in this PR campaign what
is and isn't allowed and what is and
isn't appropriate and that's a huge
battle that's that's you know drying out
on both sides but the President and Rudy
Giuliani are trying and and Devin Nunez
are trying to make it appear that the
congressional over
members of Congress have the right to
every single document and the truth is
that they don't okay we will continue to
follow obviously all sides of both sides
of this investigation